et on ces temps de rentrée c'est une
page de la crise sanitaire qui va
bientôt se tourner la fin du quoi qu'il
en coûte lancé en mars 2020 à la fin du
mois donc ces aides auront dans leur
ensemble écouter quelques 240 milliards
d'euros au budget d'état mais avec quels
résultats peut-on vraiment croire un
arrêt total de ces aides dont elles se
poursuivent d'une façon ou d'une autre
on voit se fait tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir c'est notre
rubrique l'édito échos
bonsoir jacques sapir merci d'être un
jour et en os sur le plateau je suis
ravi de vous y accueillir alors
évidemment la question qu'on se pose
aujourd'hui qu'on craint d'ailleurs est
ce que l'état va cesser c'est z avec un
retour à la quasi normale qui se profile
jacques oui alors effectivement on
s'attendait même certains le redoutent
et en s'attendaient justement à ce que
ce soit la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte
alors il faut toujours rappeler que ce
quoi qu'il en coûte il a coûté rien que
pour le soutien à l'économie
240 milliards d'euros c'est ce qu'a dit
olivier dussopt aps le ministre du
budget est globalement évidemment si on
prend l'ensemble des sommes qui ont été
déboursés sur 2020 sur 2021 et qui le
seront encore 2022 on attend 4 124
milliards d'euros ça fait beaucoup donc
est-ce que le gouvernement va pouvoir
arrêter le robinet comme cela d'un coup
ou bien est-ce qu'il sera contraint
d'une certaine manière de continuer d
aide c'est aussi une question qu'il faut
poser et j'avoue que on peut quand même
douté d'un arrêt immédiat ldu quoi qu'il
en coûte alors prenons un petit peu les
choses par le début d'où vient ce crois
qu'il en coûtait et quel bilan peut-on
en tirer bien emmanuel macron a dit
évidemment le quoi qu'il en coûte c'est
pour sauver l'économie il l'a répété
plusieurs fois ne serait ce que dans son
allocution du 12 juillet dernier bon il
faut savoir qu'à partir du moment où
l'état imposé à certaines entreprises de
manière administrative de fermer du fait
de la pandémie et des fallait compenser
le manque à gagner donc d'une certaine
we saw pas qu'il en coûte ils étaient
obligés après c'est vrai que l'état fait
beaucoup il a fait beaucoup mais est on
le voit sur le graphique 1 pas
nécessairement plus que d'autres pays la
france se situe à peu près au milieu et
puis il faut quand même dire une chose
c'est que ce quoi qu'il en coûte il a
été distribué de manière assez inégal
alors dans quelle mesure les salariés
antique justement profiter de ces aides
vous avez tout à fait raison stéphanie
les salariés ont été parmi les
principaux bénéficiaires
vous savez que dans le quoi qu'il en
coûte 50 % des salariés ont été aidées
via en particulier le chômage partiel
c'est un chiffre qu'il faut comparer 22%
seulement en en italie 20 % en allemagne
11 % en espagne après et bien quand on
regarde le cas des travailleurs
indépendants une autre partie importante
quand même de la population qui
travaille et bien c'est pas du tout
aussi glorieux en ce qui concerne les
travailleurs indépendants on est qu'au
12e rang au niveau européen donc ça
prouve bien que dans ce quoi qu'il en
coûte certains en ont profité et c'est
très bien mais d'autres ont été plutôt
laissé de côté et donc ça plutôt aggravé
les inégalités de ce point de vue là
alors jacquin de nouvelle z à la carte a
priori devrait prendre le relais mais
comment ça va se passer concrètement
c'est effectivement la grande question
le gouvernement a décidé d'arrêter les
aides forfaitaires donc de mettre fin au
fond d'eux
au fonds de solidarité le 30 septembre
et il voudrait passer à des êtres qui
serait plus ciblée alors à la fois sur
des secteurs qui ont plus souffert comme
par exemple le secteur de l'événementiel
le secteur du tourisme d'affaires
et ils voudraient aussi le recentrer sur
les entreprises qui en ont besoin après
ça va quand même posé un problème de
calcul on peut donc penser un sauf
erreur de ma part connaissent elles ne
s'arrêteront pas c'est bien ça va votre
idée oui parce que s'ils voulaient
fondamentalement d'une part il y a le
problème des prêts garantis par l'ip
alors ces prêts garantis par l'état
important 160 milliards en un an et demi
mais ces prêts garantis par l'état il
faut les rembourser ce sont des prêts de
même qu'il va falloir rembourser
les la dette sociale la dette fiscale là
on parle de report sur 2022 sur 2023
mais ça veut dire qu'il y aura toute une
somme importante qu'il va falloir
rembourser et qui peut poser problème à
des petites et des moyennes entreprises
et puis d'un autre côté on a des
secteurs qu'il va falloir continuer à
aider bien sûr qu'il ya des secteurs qui
ont profité de cette crise vous savez le
e-commerce il se réjouit plutôt de la
crise sanitaire mais il ya d'autres
secteurs qui ont été très durement
touchée et donc si on combine ce qu'il
va falloir donner aux entreprises
pour qu'elles puissent rembourser il va
falloir que l'état en fait tu payes ce
remboursement d'une certaine manière est
ce qu'il va falloir donner au secteur
qui ont beaucoup souffert et qui n'ont
pas encore et qui sont loin d'avoir
retrouvé même le chiffre d'affaires de
2019 eh bien ça va faire une certaine
somme alors en conclusion j'ai pensé mon
que sont d'autres formes le quoiqu'il en
tout 20 août va finalement perdurer oui
on peut le penser pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord il ya un fait qui est évident
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une année
préélectorale
si vous voulez on voit bien que le
gouvernement va faire toutes les
dépenses qu'ils estiment nécessaires à
la réélection des manuels macron donc ça
c'est une première chose ensuite il ya
une autre question qui est évident c'est
justement le fait que si on arrête ces
aides de manière nette on risque de
condamner à mort un nombre important
d'entreprises
le bureau d'études altares estime à 60
milles les petites et moyennes
entreprises qui sont dans une situation
de tension financière extrêmement
importante donc ça veut dire que ce mur
des faillites que l'on n'a pas vu pour
l'instant aider on pourrait peut-être le
voir en 2022 ça ferait quand même très
mauvais effet en année électorale
d'avoir une vague de faillites et puis
il y a les aides que le gouvernement
veut mettre en place et là c'est
clairement dans une logique
préélectorale le rsa jeunes dont on
parle beaucoup la suppression des impôts
de production c'est une bonne chose mais
ça représente de toutes les manières une
nouvelle aide pour les entreprises et
donc si on combine tout cela bien on
peut penser que le quoi qu'il en coûte
n'est pas tout à fait prêt à s'arrêter
on va savourer c'est un dossier qu'on va
pouvoir suivre dans les mois qui
viennent on sera réellement fixé si vos
prévisions étaient les bonnes merci jaxa
fier d'avoir été avec nous en direct
donc sur ce plateau